and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review
oh my god jeez it's a greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life hey whatever
Captain America's catchphrases mixed
with spoilers dear sea sky goodnight
Captain America and she's working for
the organization shield to help stop the
evil organization shield you see pirate
Samuel Jackson found out they're up to
no good
and so he's like Captain America I'm
gonna die yeah sure you were go with it
I'm going to die no kidding the leader
of the Avengers is going to die we put
it in the trailers we put on YouTube
videos yeah okay with your last words
tell me something vague that practically
nobody would be able to figure out trust
nobody here that's a region of this Oh
mm-hmm I really mean it I'm gonna dead
yeah where's the microchip disc DVD and
or jump drive that you want me to get
Sea Grant for me oh thank you so Captain
America wants to be sure that the jump
riders get safe so he puts in the safest
place possible
I'm vending machine that was a really
dumb idea vending machines are around
because people still use them on second
thought it's method and realistic I was
found over you like a grenade and a
vending machine once it was really spicy
so all these agents of shield tried to
get Captain America in this elevator
with his greatest nemesis taser specs
our bullets and grenades too expensive
to use they shouldn't be half of our top
secret weapon treason vending machines
apparently but Captain America kicks
their asses and so shield is like this
is the world's most wanted man we must
somehow create a giant taser stick or
something that gets through Taser sticks
at him or something that could blow up
into a giant taser stick why don't we
just shoot it yeah it works so Captain
America meets up with black widow who
has yet to have sex with somebody and
then kill them though I'm holding out
for Kent didn't exist just a win-win and
she tells what Captain America to see
what's on the jump drive and they find
this underground lair for World War two
answer that the jump drive is actually
the mind of the evil scientist from the
first one no not Red's go the one you
don't remember the one who looks like a
mix between Peter Dinklage and Francis
from pee-wee's big adventure
would you care you don't remember him
buddy's back and he's like into forties
and fifties I backed up my mind into a
computer but you guys couldn't even
invent porn yeah this was actually our
first attempt at pong and somehow it
worked its way into this science weird
what's your evil plan Tim Curry villain
from Captain Planet
we have perfected a technology that can
see the future and so we're gonna kill
all the awful people and murderers
before they become awful people and
murderers but wait when that also mean
killing the people
are killing those people and then
chilling the people who are killing
those people and then killing the people
who are killing those people this is a
stupid way
well would you expect from kind of messy
oh my god kinds of Nazis they're the
worst Heidi evil have you kind of this
kind of kind of but this other guy who
used to be dead but came back to life
and now has a metal arm I call it the L
wing soldier it's why not down Captain
American black widow to kill them and
the ORAC soldier is like you'll never
guess who I am
oh yeah sure it could be anybody it's
gonna be a real big twist big enough
that you don't show down the poster what
hi Bucky okay so wasn't a good twist but
at least you remember me well yeah
somebody has to play I played a very big
part in the last movie oh yeah sure it's
what everybody was talking about in the
last film boy not that red skull or the
Captain America guy Bucky woo he was
something hi I remember me no you really
do oh yeah you're right do I want to
kill you well let me just get my pizza
pan of America and fight ha I thought
you were more than just a shield
alright I'll lose it now lose your metal
arm no because I know that's pretty much
all I have because you're so forgettable
even putting you on the poster will make
people not remember buddy right boo so
Captain America Black Widow escape to
find out the biggest surprise ever
pirate al Jackson is still alive Oh
didn't see their command yeah I know
shit I mean you really convinced me oh
my god the prison's gone what are we
gonna do shut up shut up shut up shut up
shut up shut up shut up when I get my
own movies so they bring back into
shield toward all the good shield people
about the bad shield people and they're
like good shield people do you want the
future to be like Minority Report you
mean filled with a million plant holes
because this movie already kinda has
that just trust me a guy who's been on
the run all of you been told to kill and
I'm just asking you to suddenly take my
word all this end alright but only
because you dress like the red white and
blue pancakes from Denny's doll this big
explosive action scene happens and
there's this cool guy with wings named
Falcon and he's like I will bring back
silver heart so they stop the evil
Robert Redford obvious bad guy claim
Tyrael Jackson is dead because it works
so well the first time leave it so that
nobody's running shield for the moment
black widows ought to make her own movie
Captain America Falconer gambled for
what's-his-name
Bucky nobody cares and America is
Stanley knowing that the government is
no longer watching and listening to
every single cell
everything that we're doing and so
captain america the winter Alrik was
really great and I'm especially looking
forward to those evil siblings that they
were building up in the middle of the
credits I always thought the Wonder
Twins were DC though this is just to me
boom see judge you got sides
haha epic eyewear yes come on shine I
swear it'll go to Mickey Captain America
3 with Hillary thinking going up against
Batman and Superman